hace unas semanas serán enfermeros
abogados violinistas productores algunos
tenían experiencia militar otros no Pero
eso ya es de historia ahora todos juran
luchar por Ucrania
todos los hombres entre 18 y 60 años son
los elegibles para la conscripción estos
voluntarios defenderán quietos
nasar tiene 21 años él es violinista
estudiante del conservatorio de la
capital
mi vida estaba llena de Back paganini y
otros compositores ahora ha cambiado por
completo no puedo hacer música cuando la
gente se está muriendo
estamos escuchando algunas bombas que
sientes
[Aplausos]
sí lo siento
Ahora hay más bombardeos
solo pienso en la gente que está allí en
ese lugar y quiero que estén vivos
es de plana dejó el hospital donde
trabajaba como enfermera
para mí ni siquiera había opción mi país
está en peligro no quiero hacer ningún
discurso largo pero hay que alistarse me
viene desde el estómago si no voy yo
quién lo hará
junto a él algunos combatientes
extranjeros también como este hombre
estadounidense Aquí está hace dos
semanas después de unirse a la legión
internacional para la defensa
territorial de Ucrania él y otros
ciudadano estadounidense estaban
entrenando a voluntarios ucranianos el
entrenamiento de ayer fue bueno fue todo
lo básico y todo lo necesario para
llevarlos lo más lejos posible para que
puedan defenderse según las autoridades
ucranianas unos 20.000 extranjeros han
unido a la legión respondiendo a la
llamada del presidente bolodimir
selensky combatientes extranjeros que se
unen a los soldados ucranianos para
defender al país
[Aplausos]